who's the best guitarist of all time
quickly back Jeff back
not Jimi Hendrix Jimi Hendrix would be
of course in the starting lineup but you
put me on the spot
Prince
Eddie what doll different all different
but I was in the room with Jeff Beck
when he took a guitar out of a cardboard
box with a rented amplifier and no
pedals and created that sound when we
did the Young Guns record and he was my
guitar player I sat there flabbergasted
because Jeff Beck did things with his
fingers with his thumb that would blow
your mind wow you know so but he's
different
um Hendrix page Eddie of course would
have been Eddie Mark Knopfler I watched
you get into an argument about Dire
Straits I love Mark Knopfler completely
different style guitar player but all it
is also goes back to their songwriting
abilities too because it's integral to
the to the whole thing
foreign